good morning Millennials unfortunately
we are here today because we didn't win
the lottery but whatever whatever
there's always next time to clubs oh
where would really last night if I where
would you be right now okay so they now
sit at like 1101 mm-hmm 11:05 time it
was like 11:10 I would have been done
calling everyone friends family sisters
lovers boyfriends all that stuff
then he heard adalah Peter yeah maybe
then he would like me I could invest in
his fitness and then at like 11:30 I
would have gone out to a celebratory
dinner at like a very expensive
restaurant
um what restaurant I'm curious right
like what is the most expensive Road and
delicious but the thing is I wouldn't
have the billion dollars yet so this
would be out of pocket of course but you
could afford anything you pay yourself
back right right right I want to know
what you think is like the best
restaurant to splurge on cuz as I'm
hiding my birthday dinner that I'm just
curious I mean like it what it's like
look mister chalak I wouldn't want
something that's like a seat and I would
want to be that oh my god that's scarlet
we'll just won the lottery you know
right we're right and I would make a
stink like buy everyone a bottle of Dom
the whole restaurant but then I would
have to pay for that until I got my
money right very conflicting we're
getting ahead of ourselves because that
is a story but good morning everyone
good morning everyone
Wednesday October 24th 2018 still it's
very exciting you know for them for the
whole 2018 family house here 2018 going
so fast and honestly a roller coaster of
emotions like when I think of the lowest
pointed by 2018 in the highest point
which will probably be tomorrow God
willing knock on wood like wow do you
want to hear something Mao lowest point
of my 2018 in the highest point of the
same day on the same day I knew that
that honestly that's why I'll talk about
a rollercoaster of emotions I just I
can't believe it's still 2018 I know I'm
enjoying it though me too I'm not mad
about it I feel like sometimes when the
years over I'm like sad or like really
happy like when 2017 was over like I was
sad it was like a really good year for
me and I knew things were only gonna go
downhill and I was so right no we
thought things we thought 2017 was the
year of hard work in 2018 would be our
year well actually 2018 was supposed to
be like the originally no supposed to be
like my foundational year we're like all
the work that I was doing was gonna
build towards like a huge like and when
I look back in my career and be like wow
I did a lot for myself in 2018 um and it
just it was different you know I mean
man plans God laughs
man pluck what is it madness left God
left this is a bilingual show now
officially again trust trilingual oh
wait
quod lingual hola como estas weather
coming our el baño tengo un gato and me
see yours camarones is sounding apply
yet oh no restaurant a economy hermana
you want a restaurant with your sister
than I do actually honestly my dream is
to own restaurant what kind like a
successful one Oh what kind it's like a
neighborhood joint and I don't like I
want to be the owner actually I want to
be the owner of like an upscale trendy
restaurant that like everyone's trying
to get into but it's still comfort food
and the seats are comfortable they can
go low bar yeah oh my god yes because I
feel like if you have a trendy
restaurant you have to have like
uncomfortable chairs and like small
appetizers and like everyone's wearing
heels that they can't walk in no mine is
like a very relaxed dress code it is
still comfortable booths and large
portions family style but it's still
hard to get a reservation
yeah polo bar but like with an Italian
flair love it yeah they think someone
needs to invent that doesn't exist it's
like Mateos like what materials used to
be oh my god Mateos was our local
Italian joint oh my god and if we were
going to Mateos like it was gonna be
eight at night no you had to wear
stretchy pants to Mateos only he said oh
says kami back then like I didn't even
know what it's dressy pay right you
probably didn't even eat anything it's
like but what the last time I was at
Mateos I just wore pants like for the
sake of wearing pants I got to think
about them like are they stretchy are
they tight are they believe me nauseous
oh well they look skinny like I just
wore pants actually now the toasters are
inspiring me like I kind of would want
to own a cheesecake factory like a chain
mmm I know but it's actually uh
expensive to own at coin a franchise of
like a big chick no I would want to own
the chain I won would I would want to be
the Ray Kroc thief oh so would you go on
Undercover Boss if you did a hundred
percent a hundred percent I would
actually be so good at being on
undercover because I I can be like a
weenie in no time yeah but like you
easily recognizable look if I if they
just make me look not like myself then
they'll never know yeah I just really
feel like either owning a bar or a
restaurant besides Formica the struggle
of keeping it alive because it's like
impossible to have a successful
restaurant these days
like it's so fun so fun but it's so hard
that's like Lady gaga living the dream
like her dad owns a restaurant she's
always there it's all the food she loves
in this world and her that part of it
makes it successful named after her
Antony chess and honestly Lady Gaga
respects the hell out of her end do you
just like me we talk about just life a -
a lot and there's one moment that we
never really spoke about sure because
before the documentary I had no clue
like who or what Joanne was I thought it
was like this alter ego of hers like I
didn't know and then it turns out that
it was her dad's sister who passed away
dead out we dead on how old was she
young yeah
she died before Gaga was born right but
it's always been like that
this void in this family yeah and like
this looming presence so gaga wrote a
song called Joanne obviously and paid a
plate for the grandma in the documentary
and Lady Gaga who've never met Joanne
was like very emotional and like the
grandma who was Joanne's mom like like
didn't care
look no she did but I didn't get the
vibe that she didn't care I thought it
was like so sweet oh my god I found that
seem to be incredibly awkward oh my god
I did it I feel like the grandma was so
old like she couldn't really speak but
what she said was like that is Joanne
like that's our girl you got it right
she said okay yeah I just felt like it
was this moment for let agog I'm like
grandma like just wasn't down i I
thought like the moment was achieved
also I was thinking about last night I'm
not gonna talk about it right now but a
moment for a late like a moment like
you're talking about right now yeah do
you know that dinner there are so many
things we have to talk about four
modernizations keep coming back to me
from that room and the conversation that
we had about wedding hashtags it was so
funny cause like we were talking about
yours and Olivia's like we were just
having the conversation with all your
friends and we were just talking about
how like really we've gotten as a
society we've gotten so out of control
with wedding hashtags like basically
what started the conversation was Jackie
was like I just want it to be the
combination of me and Zach know what
happened with someone asked cuz for a
while when we got engaged we didn't have
a hashtag and I was soliciting the
toasters for hashtags and then at the
pool someone was like had you guys said
on the hashtags Accio and I was like
well that's always been our couple name
and I and it's always been the obvious
choice but I I was so caught
been like everyone else being like that
cut his jack in the well right I like a
life that I was looking past the obvious
choice right and that's a but but that
is an analogy for how society has
strayed from the wedding hashtag like
right supposed to be like a merging of
families a merging of names like
Brangelina not Brad cut his energy and
apparently not so far like I've been to
weddings where like literally the
hashtag is a blind item and like it's
[ __ ] impossible and then when you're
coming up with like the funniest
examples it's like Sarah went down to
the river to see her lover look it's so
busted
and honestly I would prefer if your
names don't match just you hashtag
Claudia and Ben like it's stupid and and
now I even get like mine was a little
stupid in mine like in the grand scheme
of the world wasn't that stupid but like
now I feel stupid you know no it's
idears was perfect and you had a great
engagement hashtag and a great
Bachelorette hashtag yeah yeah it gets
ready cloudy gets rowdy and grunged
England's what's Olivia's bachelorette
hashtag did she have one oh I'm sure
she's like living life live life with
her Zach earn my Annie it's so [ __ ]
stupid these days it makes me so mad
like I will no longer participate in I
very much wish to be excluded from this
narrative but I didn't ask to be a part
of he's funny belugas hashtag is amazing
we need to find some live love Zach yet
so and then we were talking about like
no and I used to think it you might
think sometimes I might think it should
be live Zach love but then I'm like no
no live love Zach no but when your soul
lives a club I don't think that you're
trying to imitate Live Love Laugh oh but
I think Zach sounds closer to laughs OH
Zach knows but like you just think Live
Love and then you think it's like a
thing not live Zach and like it
interrupts it I can honestly you guys
posted we're both watching on YouTube
post the worst wedding hashtag you've
heard like the one that is so far off
it's just trying so hard to make it work
no I've seen it some like really bad
ones from people who that's not whose
weddings I've been in magnitude but like
acquaintances yeah or just like things I
see on Facebook literally when I asked
for suggestions like the ones that I got
were so bad ready like Claud accepted
Ben's offer
Ben saw her it like okay look it's so
bad but that was
the funny conversation I was like gonna
bed last night like laughing I was
thinking about it too and I was like we
shared on the traits funny it was just
so funny it was so funny so anyways my
wedding hashtag is Zakia and I feel so
good about it and you know who actually
inspired me to really embrace that the
FIR agnez oh yeah
their wedding branding was so good I
don't follow either of them and I was
just like nice work people I agree like
the logo was on fleek
but yeah I keep telling to act like make
us a logo yeah and he's he won't I don't
know why he like doesn't do a first
wedding but he loves making logos he
does it's weird oh but you guys can get
to work if you're Bhutto if you're bored
at your graphic designer just like if
you need something say it if you put it
out of the universe yes believe receive
manifest destiny
it's Abed didn't work for me at the
casino and manifest sesame like doesn't
have anything to do with that isn't it
you manifest your destiny no it's like
Lewis and Clark I think like going west
well I was at eight I never rewatched
the show but I rewatched a couple of our
like segments with Peter yesterday just
cuz like obviously and I was like
literally slurring my words I have just
like I talked so fast and so comfortable
like being fast that I just don't even
speak I just like say sounds you know so
I'm really trying to slow down and
enunciate for the sake of my fellow man
should be try it also someone suggested
that for Olivia's Bachelorette we do
live in La Veta live which is cute it's
fine it's just like I would like to go
back to hashtag loves Bachelorette you
know what I mean like yeah but she has a
really good name to work with yeah
because it has so many different like
lives living large one last time that's
not bad but then it sounds like you're
calling her about no living large is
living life right baby like living it up
in Miami live yeah we'll figure it out
living that lives
that'll be house check prisoner talk to
us some of us about your inspiration
behind your outfit yes I can't because
I'm a podcast listener Jackie is wearing
I'm wearing um blue tailored pants like
ox an almost like an electric blue
slacks with a a tiny Yankees t-shirt
judge on the back Tamra son got to
support him a Pepsi oversized bomber and
heads at
have baseball embroidery on them and I
found out yesterday that the World
Series is going on because I got kicked
off the couch so that Zach could watch
it and this is just a little world
series Kauai that I'm serving up and
then I found out this morning that the
Yankees are not in the World Series no
um but I just wanted to support support
the home team and I don't know I love
commit like once I put this shirt on
like I had to put these shoes on right
and then I needed a jacket a good theme
I needed a jacket and this was the only
blue color of this blue that I owned in
the words of bebe Rexha if it's meant to
be it'll be okay baby just and actually
Pepsi sent me this jacket personally
very cool after I like really did some
major brand positivity awareness at the
Superbowl yeah you know so here we go
again I'm wearing all black because up
together on the train today and I just
felt like it was an all black kind of oh
man oh my god I'm wearing jeans on a
train I'm gonna have to change it wow
that's a horror story you know literally
girl on the treasurer jeans on a train
because Tara DG I think they did you
know I'm a tub and to bring me an extra
pair of leggings that's good or snitch
snitch is coming tomorrow snitch as a
final tomorrow morning and then she's
taking the train to Boston tomorrow
afternoon hey this a long-ass train I'm
on the Express and it's four hours what
are you gonna do well I just have so
much content to catch up on I'm gonna
watch over Dale I got to an amazing peak
in Desperate Housewives last night I
could have kept watching till 6:00 in
the morning but I had to go to bed at
like 1:00 o'clock and me and Adam were
just like dying to watch me they
couldn't sleep Ben likes to show more
than me and now he gets ahead of me it's
so annoying so it's route it's like
literally rude but we're getting through
it we're working through it I think are
adding their hashtags Margo into the
synagogue terrible why terrible why
terrible
get it terrible by the way if you showed
up like to Boston with me today like you
would get punched I would maybe I'll go
I can use a good punching yeah there's
something nuthin completes it look like
a black I know then I'm really super
World Series Kawai I feel like a lot
happened yesterday but like I didn't
post about it on the chose Instagram
because I was too busy like making fan
account content for Peter Krause
obviously by the way so I made literally
the funniest piece of content for
Instagram and if you like a lot of
people make me miss the joke because you
needed to have the sound on it was just
like a gif of Peter Krause but in the
background it was the Taylor Swift song
hours and it was like I love the gap
between
your teeth it was suddenly so funny and
then I was like we're literally changing
our user name to Peter cross fans and
obviously toaster made an Instagram
Peter cross fancy is like everybody has
like hundred followers that's a nice
sign you're posting premium content on
the daily that's amazing I guess I could
use a Peter cross fan account I was so
surprised that ended username wasn't
taken I went I'm sure he does have fan
accounts but maybe just with more clever
names I don't know yeah well I feel like
we've stalled long enough we have oh no
but yesterday was so busy because we
were creating premium content for our
patreon oh we pasted an episode that was
just like really funny and laid-back and
we try and like stick within the theme
and we tried to do that last night and
like we literally we're trying to just
talk about like home decor like being a
housewife and we literally ended up
talking about like therapy and and I
don't even know do you
yes um scary stuff very spooky stuff and
we also finally filled my home tour and
it's pretty much done except we're
having one problem which is that I chose
to wear the most unflattering outfit and
I look very pregnant and I just want you
guys to know like I'm not know it you
just look like early stages okay it
looks like it might be even like an
announcement no I look like one of those
girls who's like two or three months
pregnant who's only gaining it like
right in her tummy and I just want you
guys to know like when I am pregnant I'm
that's not gonna be me like it'll be
here right here should only be here
lucky here right like but I bet it's
really it's spooky well I thought you
looks great and I filmed it for 15
minutes at my arm was killing me so
we're not refilling it no of course not
and honestly it's really cute and all
those times that like we were yelling
I'm really pretty sorry we started I
left it all in court
it was it's just really funny we're
nothing it's not authentic great I'm you
really get a full view of my I was my
videography skills it was good while you
were doing it I was like not
understanding the vision but then it
looked really nice let's talk about art
you don't understand it till it's
complete right and there's a lot of art
in this video because I have a lot of
art so head over to patreon.com forward
slash the morning toast to subscribe and
you get access to all the old episodes
don't worry about it yeah there are some
really good old episodes
patron is just like a fun place to be
ourselves it really is I feel like I
Drive it on Instagram yeah I could say
stuff and like it really it won't get
out you know what I mean because if
you're paying for the patreon like
you're don't hate me yeah you know
hopefully I mean if you are paying for
the peach awning you need us like that's
really sad no no like I'm depressed okay
and thanks yeah yeah you paid for my
train tickets today making that picture
on Monday okay first story the world's
abuzz one winning 1.53 7 billion dollar
Mega Millions tickets sold in South
Carolina a historic occasion someone in
South Carolina just hit the jackpot the
biggest Mega Millions jackpot ever after
days of anticipation a ticket ticket
purchased in South Carolina match the
numbers 528 62 65 70 and Mega Ball 5-4
the 1.5 37 billion dollar haul on
Tuesday Mega Millions said in a press
release this person can opt to claim the
prize as eight hundred and seventy eight
million dollars cash also in South
Carolina they do have a lot that the
winner can be anonymous so we might
never find out who it was
which is like so [ __ ] sad for us you
know but like last night Ben went out
and got it like it was it was 8 o'clock
and I was like by the way I didn't get
Powerball tickets and he said oh that's
stupid we're not gonna win I'm like oh
really you're being robbed like Ross
Geller right now you're not gonna get
the Powerball ticket and he's like then
I mcfine it's stupid like we're not
gonna get it and then when I he was like
no now he arguing at it so whatever he
went and got it got like 10 numbers and
I just have to say not one of my numbers
matched like not a single one which
means no [ __ ] sends and I was so mad
and so upset and I was like literally
waiting with anticipation until I
realize like where do you go and find
the numbers like it was like 11:30 and I
was like wait where is it and then I
went and found it on Twitter and I was
like 30 minutes behind and obviously I
don't win and it's like annoying that
like many people in New York like will
never win
it's like why because it's like it only
is like they tell you before if a
winning ticket was pulled and it's
always in some like Rando state it's
never in like a New York California like
New Jersey I feel like it's in New
Jersey
no never like it's literally only in
like the south or like random no if it's
just in California last time Chino
everyone's head was Ryan Atwood who won
whatever it's never gonna be me as what
I'm saying no it's never gonna be you
but um Italy except that I remembered
the last one where should we all like
we're buying tickets for them for one
day we saw it like our lives could
change tomorrow and that sort of hope is
just like exciting wanna hear something
hilarious and crazy
I'm eating a snack and if I don't it's
okay even hungry starving yesterday and
the whole history of my life was at
least I every day you went to hell stone
I went to hill stone at five o'clock
would you get I thought it was like a
meeting so I thought we were just moving
like apps and drinks and I was like the
waiter was like do you want anything
else I'm like no I'm okay and then
everyone ordered an entree so I like I
wasn't gonna be like actually so I just
sat there while everyone ate it was like
so stupid and annoying and then by the
time I got home it was just like
whatever I didn't have lunch dinner or
breakfast yesterday I had a Reese's
Pieces at your apartment and a fiber one
bar at home and like honestly I weighed
myself this morning and I lost no weight
so I was like okay this is what's the
point
oh yeah for the last Powerball the one
in California where Ryan Atwood won me
and my friend Anna walked up in the
freezing cold up seventh Avenue looking
for a place to buy a lotto tickets like
you can't just buy it at like a
newsstand it has to be like a special
place we finally got it and the next day
like something like really terrible
happened and like my life was just like
I was too preoccupied with what had just
happened to check the tickets and I
never checked them I mean on a bologna
you have to clean your prize well
someone else wanted so like it's
impossible more than one person can win
it
what yeah if you pick if two people
could pick the same numbers and then you
split the pot but you don't pick your
numbers they're generated for you you
can pick them I'm pretty sure that we
crazy if you picked them and then you
want yeah well that's why I like some
people take the same numbers every
single time they play like every week
they pick the same numbers every time
and it's less random cuz like those are
your numbers right okay that's
interesting thinks that well maybe then
I missed out because and you have 180
days to claim your prize so I think I'm
long overdue for short that's really sad
I didn't know that well I didn't win
last night but when when I was like
before 11 o'clock like when you have you
been we're making plans he was like ever
taking the lump sum are we doing where
they pay you about what would you do
always take the lump sum take the lump
sum cuz like you never know could go
bankrupt yeah right I was dumb oh my god
of course tickle of 878 male like okay
so let me were like - binding it up as
well like we it's a habitable
Mitchell qua like equitable you have to
consider like the taxes and then once
you get the taxes you consider like
where you live so me and Ben were like
after the 1.6 billion you really get
like half so you get like 800 mail after
taxes no that's it was 878 ml if you go
all cash that's what we just read so
it's less than that oh [ __ ] so it's like
400 for after taxes it's it's 400 bill
mill oh my god so me and Ben decided
like Bale 300 mil of it is like going
into some sort of bond savings because
I'm like we want our future children to
live forever rich but like that 100 mil
we can live off of for the next Lex 50
60 70 years sure so we were like over at
the hundred mill we'll do you know
stocks and bonds but we don't know how
to do that so I'm like we got a we got
to hire someone we got we got a partner
up you know no but like in this day and
age there's so many easier ways to like
learn about stocks other than just like
having to blindly trust someone right
because I feel like all I know is like
you have to invest in steel like you
know the Sun you always say that no
there's this app called Robin Hood
that's like an investment app and it
helps you like with your stocks and
gives you like ways to learn how to
invest in what stocks to invest in and
like it's just an avenue would take 100
mil 300 mil I think they would take your
300 now I think they would take the 2
and they don't even not I think you can
afford Commission but they don't take
Commission fees at all that's legit no
it's like they feel like it's made for
people like us like it's easy to use
right no like I don't have my 300 mil
like say I have like literally two
thousand dollars savings like that I
want them to invest they would do that
that's I think that's more so what it's
really not really what else for me it's
like Millennials stocks which is all
values of stocks no the end like they
make it so easy with like charts and
market data it's just a place to trade
and just for taps on your smartphone
like you're making trades I got into the
trading business you got to be a trader
yeah so that's called Robin Hood as an
app it's an act and Robin Hood is giving
listeners a free stock like Apple Ford
or sprint to help build your portfolio
oh my god you know free stocks we saw
Kim Kardashian totally sign up at toast
at Robin Hood calm
toast dot Robin Hood dot-com to get your
free stock and start investing Wow Wow
alright me my friend and also we're not
gonna have that door a great name for a
stock at yeah I love like the symbolism
behind the name Robin no no same because
there's also the charity Robin Hood and
they're making a movie Robin Hood cuz
he's Robin in a hood mhm and it just
means so much and now you're me oh my
god is that why he's called Robin Hood
yes because he's Robin in a hood yes who
is this Robin Hood totally said in the
commercial this is funny or it's a stock
app making it easy for Millennials like
well I'm gonna get I need to get on it
because I mean I didn't win the lottery
but I just I really feel like it's in my
future and it's just funny how like
really like a fur it's it's fun cuz like
even though I technically lost like 30
bucks or whatever we spent on the
lottery tickets like I bought two hours
of like pure hope and joy and like I was
living on a cloud and like that's well
worth thirty dollars because I really
thought I wouldn't have to wake up and
set an alarm you can't put a price on
hope no I mean you could because it was
thirty dollars but like you really like
I knew I wasn't gonna win but like for a
moment I could've and just that thinking
really like elevated me it's like a
happy positive place for for the hour
that I thought I could have won the
lottery and like my life would have
changed and I just couldn't up thinking
like how much four hundred million
dollars I could really further my career
you know yeah I mean you could just pay
for play right which is what I would
have to do like we could just buy ads on
Bravo no I'm gonna billboard and like I
made the preliminary steps like a couple
months ago but then the toast had a lot
of investments in like ham toast and we
had like a lot of equipment to a mess
and we just couldn't take it on but I'm
I'm making a comeback and I think we're
gonna do it in Boston cuz like that's a
really I think that's maybe our
toastiness location but we need to have
a photo shoot oh I love I'm happy to
yeah I'm happy to pose for one also
speaking of toast endeavors uh toast
cycle which is art okay so like a ride
for gift of life tickets are going on
sale to that today so they'll first be
posted in patreon and the New York's
teens group so if you're a New Yorker or
willing to travel from the surrounding
boroughs for toe cycle its November 8th
at Bryant a toe cycle Bryant I still
think O'Brien Park
um so join the New York scene syrup or
patreon and there you can find the link
to buy a seat and if you don't live in
New York but you do want to donate there
will be an option I just think like if
if holiday season the toasters can get
together for like one cause I really
think like if every toaster just gave
like a dollar we go is like turn around
no I
we should we I we were talking about
like doing like a charity drive for the
holidays yeah so we're gonna do that
separate from yeah this but Gift of Life
is legit and I'm going to LA on Saturday
because the Gift of Life charity gala in
the charity world
he's very prestigious and it's on
Tuesday in LA and Kim is being honored
so like they offered me a ticket and I
was like of course and now I just have
to figure out how to get a picture with
Kim and me and Jackie were talking about
yes or like if I have the opportunity to
have one second with Kim what I'm gonna
have a record a video for the toasters
obviously and what should I have her say
we are talking about this on patreon so
here's my list of priorities first is
getting just a bomb photo and selfie
with Kim like lighting everything then
I'm gonna have a record a video saying
good morning Millennials then if she
still has time for me I'm gonna record a
video of her saying grab a spoon and I'm
then turning around and I'm gonna put my
face near her ass and be like eat my ass
well let's see if she's yeah I think
she'd be down yeah let em do you take a
selfie with her ass so you never know
anyways next story very relatable stuff
post Malone spent over $40,000 on post
mates last year those mates has got
receipts on post Malone he should do
endorsements just gonna say what we were
this article page six they could have
done something way better with post
Malone and post me it's like totally
Postma lates you know yeah for the
second edition of the receipt the
delivery services own the delivery
service gave some insight into what
their number one most dedicated to
customer typically orders in the past
year the 23 year old singer has
requested nearly 3,000 total items on
more than 660 orders in 52 different
countries nationwide spending upwards of
$40,000 on the app who release this
information post Malone or posts mates
post mate okay that seems like an
invasion of the security breach yeah but
maybe they are working together the
number one order from the rapper is
fittingly a 12-pack of beer but he's
also an indiscriminate fan of all things
chicken from spicy sandwiches to trays
of tenders
ordering them in copious quantities from
chick-fil-a Burger King Raising Cane's
Big Daddies and Popeyes this is like
rude and embarrassing I feel like your
post mates info and like a stay is
personal and private and did they have
the written consent of possible to
release his information wait I'm not
sure and he also they also included some
of his special requests like in notes as
for asking quote so much teriyaki sauce
on the side please and lots of soy sauce
exclamation point can express and then
at Target he made the note the most
expensive cheese board they have I'm so
chessboard oh there's a min cheese yeah
that is so funny but still I need to
know more villages 6 - if they released
like my post mates or might noobert eats
it wouldn't be like McDonald's 4 a.m.
McDonald's for a McFlurry 3 a.m. like so
embarrassing so a night's would be like
ketchup
only no special sauce ok so this is what
they released post Lee I think they must
be working with postman because it's a
article on medium called the receipt
post Malone and it's very like branded
what do you get when you combine a
multi-platinum are album artist post
Malone with the world's og delivery app
postmates Malone is what they're calling
ok great in tune happy for everyone and
by the way we meant to say this when we
were talking about the AMAs but I am
like so here for post Millican agree
more um even though I know I'm not his
like target demo or anything like I
thought he his performance was so good
like he really is a talented dude um he
was he just really likes to doubt and I
just felt like his speech is everything
about him he's like a class act
I couldn't and you just wouldn't expect
that from him just given the way that he
looks which is literally he is the
walking personification of you can't
judge a book by it's cover and I feel
like for a while people didn't take him
seriously and like he was kind of a joke
just given like the way that he looks
like his hair his teeth his face is like
his tattoos but then he like really
proved himself I just want to say I am
an OG post Malone fan I've been a fan
for years and I love that song white
Iverson and honestly I don't know any of
his new music but I just loved whatever
sin and yeah I was right yeah so I'm
glad he's getting that post mates money
you just looking there he's looking
better but like all during a me so I was
just like I just want to like buzz his
head I know and shave his say man it
doesn't even need to be buzz I just wish
she would put it in like a slick
Koni no but it's like I don't know I
want to do to get my hands on his hair
no I know her good ol wash and he takes
like so much [ __ ] for it like remember
when he was the queer eye guys tweeted
at him like why is everyone telling post
Malone to come on the show does he
really want to and then he replied he
was like know everyone just the things I
smell yeah no I think he like is very in
tune with what people think about him
which I think a lot of celebrities like
distance themselves from public like
discourse because it can be so hiring
but he like knows what people say about
him and when his plane was like circling
the sky and he lands and he's like I
can't believe how many people tweet
we're tweeting I mean that they will
hopes my plane crash like most people
wouldn't read that like most celebrities
of his stature look if you ever private
played you need not be reading tweets
about you know I know would say that
like that's so crazy
also when his plane was like circling
the sky I was so invested in this area
and I don't I don't know why because
like I just happened to hear about it
where as usual I wouldn't have and then
I would only have heard about it after
it happened but while like it was
happening I was like refreshing Twitter
which I never do nowadays ya know I just
was so worried about post e will post a
next story are you ready for it Mike the
situation Sorrentino to report to prison
in 2019 another so soon the situation
will have more time before he starts his
a month to prison term for tax fraud a
federal judge in New Jersey world Monday
that the Jersey Shore star whose real
name is Michael Sorrentino will now have
until January 15th to report to prison
it's unclear where he'll be incarcerated
he's getting married November 1st in
granting the extension the judge noted
sorentino's record of compliance while
free on bail
that's so funny cuz when joey camasta
was here he was saying he's invited to
the wedding and everyone's really
excited it's gonna be like the
celebration but he wouldn't say when it
was cuz like they were trying to keep a
private and whatever [ __ ] publication
this is just like blew up their spot
page takes November 1st and you know
where they're gonna busy Wow okay I
suppose have to circle around all of
North Jersey to find it right in our
ball gowns and they're just gotta if you
like we said if you just walk in
pretending like you're supposed to be
somewhere people will believe you Oh
first you know someone use that logic
against me we're supposed to be at the
situation's wedding completely agree did
I tell you someone you start advise
against oh yes did I say it on the show
yes oh no brother ah also like if you
knew you're going to jail in two months
this is like the opposite of lottery
hypothetical what would you do in these
two months I would eat everything
I would watch so much TV
and they consume know so I've watched so
much TV and so much that [ __ ] on my
phone that it would be like sick of
technology and sick of delicious food
then I just wanted to be off my phone
and off of all good food for months like
you over consume so then you need a
break yeah and then like a great place
to get back in shape yes Teresa looked
amazing and like he's really been
enjoying food recently as he said I was
like oh I think prison will be good for
him even though I really feel like he's
rehabilitated himself as a free man and
there's only so much we habilitation he
could do personally but I think
physically it might help yeah I agree
if you were sent to jail like what
exercise like choice gotta cheat yo got
like what would you
oh wait I don't think I'm getting to
yoga maybe hmm maybe I would get into
like journaling do they let you do that
I mean you're allowed to write so I
think I might journal exercise wise
maybe like a run but how far can you go
there's truck maybe I was at Litchfield
correctional and orange is the new black
so maybe I would pull an Archie are you
caught up on Riverdale no I'm watching
the drink J okay but it's not really
like a spoiler but he no it's okay
thank you don't say no okay um I
honestly feel like I would get into yoga
because like we were saying with Peter
crafts like I'm just not one for
physical activity and if I have to
exercise like it might as well be one
that's very low-energy like I can't do
high knees and and burpees and Sprint's
like I get really out of breath and like
I will throw up I get this pain between
my boobs and it hurts so bad and they'll
let her up everywhere so if you like
yoga might be good for me because it's
like you can really get a workout and
get into good shape without actually
like running you know with just like
laying around I'm like your heart rate
doesn't really go well I'm even like
really fake it no yoga's like [ __ ]
but you can [ __ ] it yeah I mean
shavasana
do you know how to shavasana no it's
honestly it's one of the most like
complex poses and yoga a dive master
snitch and I did a hot yoga class once
and I don't know why we were laughing
the whole time that's so bad cuz like
you probably get a lot of breath we
couldn't stop laughing it was like there
was like laughing ass with the steam and
we're laughing so hard and then we just
passed out on the floor of the class but
I did it you know slept and the teacher
thought we were so relaxed and we really
were what was the weirdest experience
ever
that is weird I couldn't stop laughing
that's so funny hot yoga man but we're
really breezing through these stories
which is honestly Gore
because your toasters and I just like
let me get to talk about ourselves more
it was gonna say like I can't be
bothered with talking about other people
for that long no but this is what
happens when we do like celebrity news
it's like it's it's right it's fickle
and fleeting much like some match or
friendships according to reach Oh
Lindsay woo remember no these bachelor
friendships are fickle and fleeting oh
she said she's so wise he's a poet in
New York oh she's in New York I know I
was thinking so I need a co-host for
Thursday Friday so I was stalking
revolve cuz they're all in the or that's
by the way that's so great for us it is
but then I was looking at all the people
who are here and like it's it's everyone
who's like skinny and boring right like
I don't even think any of them really
have like a YouTube channel are you free
to co-host tomorrow or Friday yeah and
then there was one other person from
remembering my axe but it's not oh you
just Kendall no I might I'm gonna have
to get creative
oh my god I honestly all these you know
both suspects are busy jagged look at my
dams like it's just like another day I
wake up with the D I'm from Greta
Paltrow and like honestly I can't
believe that we're pen pals and I don't
want to talk about because I don't wanna
like make it a big deal so like listen
maybe you really did win the lottery
the friendship lottery okay next story
Taylor Swift donates to fan struggling
with medical bills Taylor Swift has
donated fifteen thousand five hundred to
a GoFundMe account of a fan whose family
is struggling with medical bills
Sadie Bartels mother has been in a coma
for three years and the family is
worried about losing their Orem Utah
home because of mounting medical bills
the 19 year old tweeted that her mother
became ill two days before she went to
see Swift in concert Swift made the
donation over the weekend with the
message love Taylor Meredith and Olivia
Swift Meredith and Olivia are Swift's
cats yeah Meredith Grey from Grey's
Anatomy and Olivia Benson
okay so it's just so funny cause I heard
she named it after Olivia ashtray I
heard that also actually hundreds near
50 speaking of conspiracy theories I'm a
truce 50 so Ike I knew this story a week
and it's just so funny how like if she
get to know play the may be like who
wrote this up uh paid six okay like via
ap okay fine but like no one covers it
wears like when Chrissy Teigen donated
$5,000 to that girl's cosmetology school
like everyone BuzzFeed is like and then
they yeah and it's like please [ __ ]
Taylor Smith literally saving lives over
here before fifteen thousand five
hundred which is oh my god my shoes ur
which was like a weird number for like
why fifteen thousand five hundred gets
completed that no it
/ so like I was just I was thinking like
why 15,500 but the girl I was like on
her tumblr and stuff she's like a
hardcore swept teen she has been for
years and it was just so sweet and so
nice and this is a great story but the
reason why I asked Jackie to cover it
it's because I read conspiracy theory
this morning that I must share and when
I started reading it I'm like oh this is
just a bunch of boob hog a feather I got
that word from Orson Hodge he's been as
obsessed with order send he's like such
a [ __ ] nerd Orson and it's I love it
michio didn't like but his him and Bree
like their burr be like don't tell me
people can't change oh my god I couldn't
agree more
okay so this is someone posted it in the
Stevie Swifties group which is our
subgroup of the morning toasters for
people who are just obsessed with Taylor
and we share conspiracy theories we
share photos we share everything and
this is a theory that when I heard it I
was like this is so stupid
and not all the points are really good
but there are a few points that really
shook me it's a theory about John
Mayer's album to search for everything
and reputation okay so here are some
facts it's gonna take me well I'm gonna
sit back yeah but I need you to listen
cuz that first you know me actually
dreaming and I was like this makes no
sense so this is their dating history
okay they dated in 2008-2009 they
recorded half of my heart together for
his album and he says that he was like
looking for the stevie nicks to his Tom
Petty which by the way half of my heart
is the greatest song and on my Amazon TV
and whenever I say play John Mayer which
is like what I like to hear buddy - they
always play half of my heart and it's
just great then he performs your body's
a wonderland at her concert and he was
interviewed many times like praising her
songwriting abilities saying she's so
talented in such a genuine person those
are the facts and here's a little bit of
a timeline she when they broke up she
released Dear John Dee in 2010
honestly I really am thinking about
launching a Taylor Swift podcast like I
just find like I have so much to say
like I could do a whole episode on this
conspiracy theory okay but I just don't
know what I would call it Stevie's so
she released here John in 2010 they John
Mayer was reported to be humiliated by
it and he responded in 2013 with
paper-doll you're like twenty two girls
in one
that was a good tongue but none of them
know what they're running from
burn obviously just based I don't know
about you but I'm feeling 22 okay so in
2016 both of them attended Gigi's
birthday party there were reports that
John Mayer was desperate to speak to
Taylor but that's all we heard in June
of 2016
Taylor broke up with Calvin and then
June to August she was with Tom
Hiddleston middle so it what ever their
names were
yep and then in October after she's
single in October her and John Mayer
both attended Drake's birthday party in
November a month later after the
birthday party he released love on the
weekend from his new album emoji of a
wave or the search for everything sorry
a month later again in December if
they're both single he tweets shade oh
my god the owner of my apartment called
me a litter every day a month later he
tweets shade on Taylor's first birthday
then January to May so this is eight
months still single
she's starts dating Joe Alwin in May
2017 John Mayer releases his whole album
the search for everything November 2017
Taylor Swift released his reputation may
2018 John Mayer randomly releases the
song new light so those are just facts
that'll come that'll you'll need to know
in the beginning so now they're
comparing lyrics from his most recent
album and her most recent album and at
first I was like this is so stupid
but buddy not does this have to do with
the charity thing
no oh whatever the 15,500 job no this is
a conspiracy theory that was the
conspiracy theory I'm so sorry no no it
was spring bull I got ok I was just like
waiting for it to connect back to 15,500
so we are not comparing and I'm sorry I
don't know where this conspiracy theory
stems from if you have a source please
let me know but I just found it in the
Stevie's fifties so um love on the
weekend is a song that he released I
really need to like reorient maybe it'll
all come back it'll open up just cuz
I've been okay so love on the weekend
goes like this you'll be the deej and I
shouldn't say I should just say you'll
be the DJ I'll be the driver you put
your feet up in the getaway car I'm
flying fast like a wanted man I want you
baby like I can't understand 1111 make a
wish I wish that Taylor's but soon
everyone is like is that
where this is headed no okay just listen
then they obviously compared to getaway
car basically what this person is saying
is like if you listen to both of these
phrases it literally sounds like they're
telling the same story from different
purview so he said you'll be the DJ I'll
be the driver you put your feet up in
the getaway car I'm flying fast like a
wanted man I want you baby like you
can't understand okay Taylor Swift song
getaway cars you were driving the
getaway car we were flying I'm flying
fast but we'd never get far don't
pretend it's such a mystery think about
the place where you first met me so when
I first saw this I'm like all right
that's weird but like a getaway car it's
like it's not the most it's a popular
phrase like it's not the craziest thing
then Taylor Swift's song dancing with
our hands tied goes a little something
like this
I it's hard for me not to sing it I
loved you in secret first sight yeah we
love with you at first sight yeah we
love with that reason 25 years old
how were you to know my love had been
frozen deep blue but you painted me
golden so this is a nod to her previous
lyric in Dear John when she said didn't
you think 19 was too young so now she's
saying oh now I'm 25 years old okay okay
there's and then there's a lot of like
golden blue recurring themes so she was
like deeply but you painted me gold in
this I'm not really concerned with
here's where things get interested and I
was like the blue for me hearts back to
Harry Styles blue tries him leaving her
on a boat of course and the deep they
were this are conspiracy theories like
golden and then the gold you left you've
left your mark on me a golden tattoo at
both of the parties that they both
attended like literally in the past
three years they've been at two parties
at the same time both times Taylor Swift
left the party wearing golden flash
tattoos and one of them was an angel
wing and there's a reference to enjoying
I don't think that's really a big deal
here's where they convinced me okay so
um no no sorry yeah yeah mm-hmm dancing
with our hands tied this is where I
forgot really I loved you in spite of
deep fears that the world would divide
us so baby can we dance through an
avalanche say say that we got it I'm a
mess but I'm the mess that you wanted Oh
cuz it's gravity holding you with me
John Mayer song dragging wait next I'd
kiss you as the lights went out swaying
as the room burned down my dear we're
slow dancing
a burning room and she says it twice the
swaying as the room burned down so that
is in one song two very obvious
references to John Mayer's two biggest
songs arguably gravity and slow dancing
in a burning room Wow I really thought
dancing with our hands tied was about
someone else well so now it's like this
is so when I first read the conspiracy
theory about Taylor Swift and Carly
Claus I was like this is so stupid and
the girl reading and I'm read it I was
like oh my god you're insane then if
you've listened to some of her music
through that purview it's like oh damn
this isn't crazy so I am now going to
read listen to reputation on the train
through the lens of like her and John
Mayer Reese rekindled so this this
conspiracy theory isn't necessarily
saying that that they're back together
no but there's just lots of nods to
maybe something happening and they're
the couple month overlap where they were
both single and then a couple month
later released new music that could be
about one another right or just like
they are engaged in this like every time
a new album comes out like you're
responding to your latest dish track in
a subliminal way also her song
Wonderland which was a bonus track from
1989 your body is a wonderland and he's
saying that at her concert not that's
not explicit but it could be no I just
feel like they are simply like I don't
think that they are together or were
together honestly I think they couldn't
be more wrong for each other but I think
they keep just responding to each
other's dish tracks and it's like a cute
thread yes but then there's one more
that shook me less then slow dancing in
a burning room tell them okay someone
says or she's writing his songs for him
maybe where they had the same songwriter
oh my god tell us what just not a song
right I know but you never know John
Mayer new light the random song that he
released like a couple months after
reputation and I never put this together
but now it freaks me out his lyrics I'm
the boy in your other phone lighting up
inside your drawer all at home all alone
maybe you're right
to doubt me hmm delicate phone lights up
my nightstand in the black so he was
saying your second phone is at home in
your nightstand and her thing is saying
my phone lit up in my nightstand
night stand she said though and he said
in a drawer no hers is he says in the
drawer in your nightstand oh she's so
particular I mean she's so general phone
lights up my nightstand
something's up on the boy and your other
phone lighting up inside your drawer at
home all alone her she responds phone
lights up my nightstand see I'm telling
you there's something there is something
who do you think is her is her one true
love we hold under my tongue so deep
blue when you painted me golden okay
that's like whatever
it's a weird and the golden tattoos
thing I wasn't into but his song paper
dolls that he released about her here's
a dress of gold and blue it sure was fun
me and good to you I'm just saying
there's something there then there's
some like nods to like some of his
outfits in their music videos and I
don't believe it but I don't believe it
I don't believe it Wow but basically do
you think I kill her to breathe this and
she's like yes my fans are so smart or
she cycle laughing so most assume this
is what the final thoughts on the
conspiracy theory are most people assume
that all the songs on reputation are
about Tom Hiddleston and Joe and most of
the songs on the search for everything
is about Katy Perry but this girl is
posing another theory that's in it Joe
Owen yeah sometime all the songs on
reputation are search for everything
which is John Mayer's album like from
maybe two years ago was worried about
Katy Perry who you loved was definitely
not Katy Perry and like um I still feel
like you're mad that's definitely out
Katy Perry - and he said that it is
about her but okay but like I was
feeling like reputation was about like
Kim Kanye Carly it's definitely about
that - I mean Carly unconfirmed but Kim
Kanye for sure like endgame oh and Katy
Perry wolf in sheep's clothing yeah yeah
yeah look what you made me do yeah but
the romantic ones okay so this is what
the final thoughts are some time between
May 2016 and December 2016
Taylor and John reconnected and had a
short secret romance and wrote some
songs about it there are two they're
pretty careful about their words while
Taylor has moved on it seems like John
Mayer still might be waiting for her but
it could all just be a coincidence but
go listen to their latest albums with
new ears which is
exactly what I'm gonna do on my train
I'd exciting yeah
just like just an interesting theory I
wanted to put out there I'm appreciated
who do you think is her one true love
okay like who is her like the one that
honestly like I think it's beyond repair
but for a while I really did think it
was Calvin Harris I think of all the
people she's dated he was my favorite
for so many reasons like she's so like
she lives in another universe like she
is so rich and so famous like I don't
think she's will ever go to a grocery
store ever again like that's how rich
and famous she is and the fact that like
she was flying to Vegas on a private jet
and going to a club like and listening
to him deejay was just like so something
like we do not the jet but like it's
just when you would you if your man was
a deejay and it was just like yes girl
you're 25 new most famous beautiful
skinny pretty girl in the world like
live your life and Calvin Harris for a
while like really brought out the normal
side of her and made it like sometimes I
really feel like she's a grandma and
Calvin Harris they really made me
reminded me that she was 25 no it's like
I want I wanted him to be it for her but
I felt like their relationship was so
fake the whole time only further proven
by him going to the massage parlor for a
happy ending okay totally that's a man
who was in an unhappy relationship just
please like she is the [ __ ] goddess
like she did not be giving hand jobs and
if Calvin Harris wanted one like
honestly I'm sure she was fine with it
like just go like I just felt like it
was always fake and then like that was
like when she realized she needed to
break up with him but she needed to wait
long enough so it didn't look like that
was why she was breaking up with him
like I feel like I didn't think it was
always fake oh my god I felt like it was
so fake so like I Heart Radio like I'm
gonna totally disagree but like best
female artist best male artist let's get
together and also like no you never even
wrote a song about him like that's how
little she cared well no we never didn't
like she never put out music about
Calvin Harris
yes she did no she didn't there's a lot
of ties to him in repetition you but you
said reputation is about Tom oh yeah and
Joe I actually think he's a getaway car
it's like I was with Calvin and then I
got in the car with Tom Hiddleston I
actually think Tom Hiddleston was like
the most in love she's ever been I don't
think so at all
I really thought they were gonna and I
never found out what happened but I have
a theory that like do you see like the
world was taken by Thunder literally Stu
storm with this couple and he went back
to Australia for work and he went for a
jog outside his apartment building and
he obviously didn't know that there
would literally be like news cameras and
literally thousands of people waiting
for him and he stopped and talked to
like a local news anchor and he was they
were like what do you think he just like
spoke about it where I feel like Taylor
was like you're not even equipped to
handle this goodbye
I thought it was a weird thing that he
did that cuz like come on like I know so
he's like a movie star like right he's
not a thirst monster same Instagram know
so I don't know what happened but I do
think that weird interview has a lot to
do with it interesting and then just one
more thing from this junior striptease
group that I wanted to share is someone
to the thread of like um like you're
like one of your favorite and like most
deep taylor swift lyrics that like
really shook you okay and I just thought
that the their responses
we're so interesting cuz mine I don't
know what mine is but um actually I do
it's from never grow up I just realized
everything I have is someday gonna be
gone that's so sad she was like a kid
just like think about how much she loved
her family and then she was like wait
like all my family's gonna die one day
and I'm just gonna be alone how's that
is that that's really what is your
favorite Taylor Swift's lyric I don't
know I would have to like go I'd have to
go on a deep dive well I just found out
that um I'll stop talk about this in a
second I just found out that handsome
you're a mansion with of you means I'm
like once I didn't think anything of it
I was just hiding like yeah handsome
Urim engine with a view it means you're
a mansion so you're beautiful on the
outside but you have a view inside
you're gorgeous on the inside too like
what a [ __ ] compliment yeah I would
love for Taylor strip to write a song
about me and that's what Harry Styles
said someone in an interview was like
how do you feel like with style when it
came out like that your ex-girlfriend is
writing songs about you and he was like
honestly if someone's gonna write it's
talking about me like I'm happy it's
Sarah swept she's the most amazing
songwriter and like it is what it is so
I'm happy whoever is doing it is good at
her job
totally what respect it's not like some
sad write like imagine like [ __ ]
Halsey - ah yeah yeah you know that's
when she dated Jake Gyllenhaal like and
that's why people say that's who all
Tyrell is about even though it's
unconfirmed but like that song all too
well
is about like the greatest love story it
has to be and the fact that it's about
Jake Gyllenhaal like shakes me to my
core and one of her greatest lyrics is
in there too
so cash oh wait mmm so there you go
again just to break me like a promise so
casually cruel in the name of being
honest like he was just trying to be
honest with her and everything he was
saying was so cruel in the most casual
way the truth hurts
it truly does um the Kennedy kid oh my
god and that one like red was really
about I mean razzle kennedy okay we
spoke about this like a year ago and you
said 1989 and I just like my but very
what the best album and you said that
like in a few years you'll look back and
you would think that her best album was
99 no I didn't you said that no I did it
cuz I didn't I didn't think it's red
always for me it's red always - and you
said that I swear you did and then it
stuck with me a lot cuz now I've been
listening to 1989 so much I've been
watching the world tour like every time
I go get on a plane and I now look back
at the 1989 era thinking it is her most
her best or her best album her best
bonus tracks and New Romantics isn't
even a [ __ ] song on the radio plane
those are her bonus tracks for people
who bought about Target and it's
probably her best song and I was just
gonna say I agree with you you're so
profound but now you're claiming you
didn't say that no what I what I did say
was that for right now 1989 is probably
like my least favorite just because all
the songs are so overplayed and in a few
years I will look back at that album
much more favorably than I do now
well I am like read everything about red
is underrated in state of grace you're
my Achilles heel totally like I think
top 5 Taylor Swift songs all too well
state of grace which both come from the
same album New Romantics okay Wunderland
no not one time wildest dreams okay
and I don't know okay for me uh-huh
state of grace is my number one you
belong with me as my number oh yeah
because it's it's had such an impact on
my life and it is responsible for the
birth of the scenes like what would I
call ourselves it is a true crossover of
pop and country like in its essence in
its essence
number three
those two are just like another ABBA
oh all too well holy ground every time I
hear Olli Bradish what I bought my
shoulders and like five might be like
don't blame me
or worry I love getaway car but it's
it's not as complicated as the others
it's not as like I can process
reputation yet like I can the other
albums because it's so new and fresh and
I really would need a new album to
understand reputation better which is
exactly what happened to me with 1989
like I loved 1999 when it was out but I
was like okay great what's axe and then
reputation came and I like longed for
1989 and I think that's gonna happen
with the next era no I totally
understand me I need to go look at my
playlist at best Taylor Swift songs just
in case we're forgetting any honorable
mentions I mean and I just think she so
we were talking I'm a couple months ago
about her music contract it's gonna be
like one of the biggest in the business
her time is up with her current label is
she gonna stay is she gonna go but part
of her current contract it she has to
release a greatest hits album so people
think that it might be before her
seventh album and I'm not gonna lie I
would absolutely love a greatest hits
album but I don't want a greatest hits
album of like her top ten songs I want
underrated songs that need to be
remastered like out of the woods I think
is her best song but only the way that
she sings it on tour not the way it was
released um long live oh of course
oh my god of course of course yes of
course and that's that songs about the
fans and she is saying it every single
one of her tours like inspiring yeah I'm
a she really loves us really cares about
us and she still loves show 100% and she
enchanted also and she did a mix up I've
enchanted and while the streams at her
concert and they sound better as one
song and then they do is - that's funny
yeah you see me in hindsight I don't
know how to use my phone I could talk I
could really like I believe I sleep a
tree I'm at it oh my god that's such a
good idea okay but I really feel like I
want to start like a Taylor Swift
podcast I would just need to find others
who are like so deeply invested in like
the swifty vibe like I feel like I might
even have like toasters on it cuz the
toasters know so much you know more and
there are a lot of toasters who have
been invited to secret sessions because
they've been like fans for so long
this one girl in Stevie's 50s posted a
throwback photo she was invited to
Taylor Swift's Rhode Island house for
the night for reputation secrets
listening sessions right red no no 1989
she said it was a year ago so
simply oh then it would have been
reputation yeah and she had pictures and
I was like did they give you the address
how to work do they fly you out she said
you get invited you have to make your
way to one location which was like a
hotel in Rhode Island and then they sent
buses her brand from the Rhode Island
tap to the Rhode Island yes yes no just
like wondering had the logistics ago and
it was just like Taylor is the only
person who ADA has never charged for a
mean greet her whole life you can't buy
a ticket to mean green it's literally
only to the people who like love her
which is way should be like just because
you can afford meeting rate doesn't mean
you should get it totally and she's
literally never once charged people
every time she doesn't mean green she
partners with some organization she
printers a lot with Autism Speaks I just
[ __ ] love her but we do need to move
on but just shows that um I think that
was our kind of story yeah I was gonna
do to your toasters oh yes okay Oh
another oh we know we do have one more
story oh my god Wow word up and also
someone suggested that we do with dear
toasters about I'm sorry a patreon about
dear toasters like what won't be like
beyond to the tank beyond the tank tier
toaster style which I'm so down for I'm
sorry we almost forgot this Phaethon
vile story which is like a Loki story I
just wanted to draw attention to it
because it's horrific socialite an
alleged Jew bashing gets community
service what socially Jacqueline can't
cook was it you know took a plea deal
Tuesday in her assault case in which
she's accused of calling an elderly
woman a Jew before bashing the woman's
son in the head with a glass clutch
outside a Manhattan restaurant what
what's wrong
um I just I want to visualize that I I
have to I don't know if it's here then
cook the daughter of late Washington
Redskins owner Jack Kent Cooke copped to
disorderly conduct which is not
designated as a crime and was sentenced
to three days community service for the
New Year's Eve Millay outside Upper East
Side eatery kurbashi owes I don't know
me neither but Upper East Side's and
like why should they imagine Upper East
Side like the nice Jewish the Jewish
landing place by motherland and you get
bashed in the head oh my god first of
all like three days of community service
like that's literally like just a J in
life for me like every day it's like
that's nothing no and also like this is
being treated as dis or
conduct but if she called someone a Jew
and I should hate crime also I love I
just like saying Jew is like is like
he's automatically negative no but it's
like if she hadn't said Jew we wouldn't
know you were bashing them because
they're Jews also it's like if she had
said like Jewish person and then bash
I'm like it might not have been it's
like there's something about the word
it's like and you're to say you can't
just say Juliet's a Jew
no but that's what's that's what's crazy
is that like Jew is now you would
perceive it as an insult because like
people have made it that way which is
why now people say Jewish no other
religion is Christian ish
but like you want to be less Jew because
like you don't want to get bashed in the
head right and I find that like even as
a Jewish person who like everyone I know
is Jewish I don't even say the word Jew
but like and new sounds like a dirty
word it does that's it's just but
there's nothing just a short version
like a Jewish no it's it's crazy but I
feel like the Nazis really ruin that
word cuz they we're all like oh you
dirty Jew Judenrat like they ruined it
amongst so many no so now when you say
the word you like it has that Jew back
no as you should the scuffle began as
haberkorn was leading the fancy fancy
eatery with his family that's the the
kid and the millionairess allegedly
barked at his mom hurry up you Jew
haberkorn confronted her in the erotic
blonde allegedly clocked haberkorn in
the head with her $400 Lulu Guinness
women Chloe mirror perspex clutch
specific and they're leaving a bloody
gash on his head woo cook claimed at the
time that haberkorn 'he's mom had simply
misheard her oh please I like okay Wow I
always it's a shocking that the daughter
of the Washington Redskins owner is
influencing the same thing like as if
the Redskins don't have enough
controversy on their hands but you know
I think all the time cuz I just someone
sent me a video was so sad literally
this man in the street like in Brooklyn
like running up to old like old very
senile Jewish men and like literally
beating the [ __ ] out of them in the
middle of the street and no one got out
I know and it's like I live in New York
and like this things like this happen
very frequently and like I never see it
and not that I want to see it but like I
just want to get involved like I wish I
was there and this is a blonde like
socialite I could tell I could even take
her like I would have [ __ ] knock this
[ __ ] out and not that I like I'm asking
for it or I want this happens me but
like I would either like to be in the
vicinity or like haven't happened to me
because I'll [ __ ] knock you out like
I'll [ __ ] kill you
like well you know no but the point is I
like that what was the driver of the cab
like got out of his car cuz this old
Jewish man was like alone and
defenseless like I don't I think if you
were around to protect him like he
wouldn't have assaulted but he just like
saw a Jew bashing moment and there are
so many of these instances that like you
probably don't even see on the news or
like in totally local like right and
it's like is this 1939 Germany or
America no it's so sad and it's like
always old met and like leave him alone
no because there'd like the most
offensive I know if they got like a
young virile man right it wouldn't it
wouldn't be if like have you ever
experienced like direct anti-semitism
it's like hard because we grew up like
in New York and like this Jewish like
thing but like have you ever um not
direct anti-semitism but I've definitely
been around people who like I got
anti-semitic Bob Sherman and they said
like anti-semitic things not like to me
or about me but just like about Judaism
yeah I feel that I've to instance one of
the pros of going to Colgate you can
expect to meet some anti-semite I mean
that's so true I can't think of too
often I've been there eat I know three
hop of my head I know three anti-semites
you do yeah I mean like I'm not close
with them but I just course no there's
like yeah I'm not friends of them I have
two instances where I'm it was a first
one now I'm forgetting my lunch is
getting really bad okay hold your time
hmm two instances of when you were
directly yeah felt like I don't remember
wow that's really bad I had it in my
head
whatever well and then there's also like
people who look like the people were
getting beat up in the street are like
people he was alert like you Barry I
wish yeah right and you definitely
wouldn't know that I'm Jewish
it's like let's just stop beating each
other up if like for like like
unprompted unprompted for just like
being of a certain religion gender or
like sexual orientation like I'm still
not here for it did you see there's this
oh actually that was kind of a while ago
like this man beat up a gay couple and
his picture is going viral I don't know
if they ever found him we should find
him no but that sounds familiar
okay if you can't remember your story
dear to another camera my choice
okay so as you guys know dear toasters
is our advise segment section advice
segment period if you want to ever
submit you can submit to dear toasters
at gmail.com we will take any of your
requests but we really enjoy the weirder
ones which brings me to our first one
good morning Jackie oh now ma I just
want to start out by saying we can also
do in Livio know Mao cuz then we could
just like keep saying now with an I
should have done cloudy oh no mo I just
start out by saying I'm a fellow
ballstein and can't wait to meet you
guys tomorrow well sorry lady so let me
jump right into my situation I work at a
young marketing agency but 300 employees
and unfortunately when I started in June
my team didn't have any seating in their
section I'm located as a desk to the
left of my team with only one other
person behind me the worst person of all
time
let me start off by describing what she
looks like even though look shouldn't
determine an opinion of someone she's
older for the age group here long red
hair down to her ass crack covered in
piercings huge silver hoops up and down
both ears I didn't even I don't even
know her name but she does for work or
anything else about her all I know is
that she sneezes and blows her nose five
to six times an hour every single day
since I started working here my first
week she claims she had bad allergies
but here we are four months later and
hasn't stopped let me add this isn't a
graceful thing it's foul and loud and it
sounds like she's blowing out her
intestines
I turned the toast on with full volume
in my headphones and can hear can still
hear her snot loud and clear the worst
part she does it while I eat lunch at my
desk like where's the respect I honestly
do not know what to do about this I
would message email her but I don't even
know her name
my whole team laughs about it but I need
to say something to her without causing
a scene SOS I can't block out the sound
any longer I would love to hear your
thoughts and advice on the situation
each other but the HR seasoned HR solves
most of our toaster related problems but
depending on the size of the company or
whatever they might not have a shower
this is a 300 person company so they
probably do but if they don't here are
some suggestions um subscribe to our
patreon so you have content all day
that's a great suit to listen to - why
don't you talk to your team about
getting moved closer to that like the
someone has to be able to shift Leno or
like you if you're not this person's
boss like you don't need to tell them
like how to behave so you should tell
your boss who tells their boss who tells
them yeah like - beep ed that's an
uncomfortable boss conversation and and
that's some of the responsibilities that
go along with the privileges of being a
boss sometimes what I like to do if I'm
like uncomfortable like wanting to tell
someone that something they're doing his
father mean I was like I will be visibly
upset when they do it like she starts
blowing her nose and I'll be like oh oh
like slam my hand down on the table bro
my eyes not again like talking to myself
and like then over here maybe she won't
over the sound of her own bellowing but
if you're like some gestures might help
convey the message right or leave an
anonymous note deer run the other night
when you left your desk yeah all your
fish honors I place between my breasts
no that's a good idea write an anonymous
letter it worked a person I can jam out
it can work out for you yeah or just
like we're a desk transfer and this
shouldn't be so hard like yeah I just
like I hate when people aren't
self-aware like most of our deer
toasters the issue the court issue is a
lack of self-awareness on the behalf of
someone this is weird that she's
sneezing year round having snot you're
I'm worried about because it's like when
I'm sick like I love a good sneeze and I
don't stop blowing and I get it all out
better out than in as Shrek says breathe
better not been in but that only goes on
for like a week so sorry for the week of
pain but like I'm healing myself for
this to be an ongoing problem is strange
no it's strange and it's concerning from
a medical standpoint for my professional
medical point of view I think she should
see someone about it
I agree all right sounds like Ben oh my
god totally this is oh my god this is
definitely one for Ben's office using a
pseudonym and making it say that it's a
girl so how about if I worked with then
I would sock him in the throat
no you just call his wife he shall come
down and fix it and with some zyrtec
yeah or you call their mom if they're
not married like
is the most effective way to get through
to them at any age depending on like how
you were raised or what type of
relationship you have with your parents
like tattling on them to their parents
is the only way to get through to
someone really get through to them yeah
like Brianna camp-style yeah
well thank you for your submission that
was a good one a very interesting one
we've never had something like that
before
this I'm by the way all the dear trusses
are anonymous so I have a feeling
whoever wrote this one doesn't want to
know that it's them and we go his name
know me I help my college roommate just
came out to me by telling me he likes
the same guy as me I seriously need
advice I'm a freshman guy in college
just looking for love snookin for love
and I'd like this one guy for about a
month now we've gotten close and I
really think
than happen even though I'm not his type
my roommate knew I was gay before we
were even roommates but I didn't know he
was until two nights ago when he told me
he had a crush on the same guy as me
keep in mind I never disclosed to him
who I liked it just so happens that he
likes him too and he's more of my
crushes type what do I do
I obviously supporting him in his
sexuality but at the same time I never
thought my roommate who I thought was
straight would have a better chance of
getting close to my crush than I did I'm
having a difficult time being empathetic
to him during this new stage in his life
because of who he likes I feel like I'm
being selfish love a non female non
millennial loyal toaster it's like okay
so you want to be supportive friend and
like obviously in his own way like this
was his roommates way of like coming out
to him but it's like you're on you want
my man but he doesn't know that's the
name he wants yeah this is tough it's
tough but do we know confirm that the
crush is straight or gay I would assume
should we know yeah I'm a suit I'm
assuming we know honestly I think this
is just a case of like let the best man
win let the chips fall where they may
like I think you can support your friend
while also like getting a leg up in the
competition you know literally literally
no I have that leg up but it's like I
don't know it's like you want to be
supported and maybe like yours you are
innately selfish and like you are saying
that you want which I totally understand
um but I think that there is a way to do
both you know yeah
honestly I'd like what almost when she
hadn't told you it was like knowledge
it's not power it's like if you didn't
know ignorant says bliss ignorance isn't
just kept going on and had sex with it
either you liked not knowing that your
roommate liked to him maybe you should
pretend like you're deaf and you didn't
hear a lot like you thought he was
talking about someone else or like you
were just so overwhelmed that he was
coming out to you that you like Oh crash
hey what what's a crush I didn't even
hear that part
yeah I'm just so happy for you know like
I thought it'd be like I thought the
point of the conversation was just like
you coming out and I thought that was so
special I didn't hear anything else
right that's a video and our final one
is an update because last I'm the - the
last beyond the toast the last time we
did dear toasters we did something about
being harassed by the weatherman with
the air conditioning units do you
remember it was a girl it was she were
excited an Eric a commercial air
conditioning company and their local
weatherman
it's getting a unit and it was like
really great for the company he was like
he's like a local slab and he was making
her very uncomfortable kept wanting to
meet alone and she had asked me taken
off the case and they wouldn't take her
off okay
I'm back with an update my dear toasters
was read on the show a couple weeks ago
my advise request was regarding a
weatherman that was stopping by
unannounced and kissing me on the cheek
etc I hope that rings a bell
anyway you all suggested that I write
everything down take it back to my boss
and basically put my foot down I took
the advice and here's what happened I
want to make it as easy to follow up so
I'll map it out
she wrote literalist a numbered list one
I took a written statement of what
happened to my coworker let's call her
Pam she's the closest thing we have to
HR since my past attempts of telling my
boss were ignored - my boss sends me and
I am and asked for my progress on
assignments that were in relation to the
creepy weatherman three I replied that I
will send the assignment to him tomorrow
but I'm not comfortable working with
that guy alone for the boss doesn't
reply five the next day
wow what a dick the next day I sent him
a detailed email of everything that
happened and that it's unacceptable in
that I need to do something he doesn't
reply six the next afternoon he calls me
the boss back into his office to discuss
my email this meeting includes me my
boss and Pam the co-worker my boss
apologizes and says that they will
terminate the relationship with their
mother man yeah my boss says quote if
something like this happens don't be
afraid to tell someone if you're
uncomfortable telling me then tell Pam
yeah dick I did tell Pam and that [ __ ]
is a tank and I told you twice nine he
tells me that he's going to send a
letter to the weatherman firing him ten
the next day he sends me an email that
says he is sorry he mailed the letter
this morning to fire the guy and I won't
have to deal with him again the letter
was attached I opened the letter and it
reads you are oh my god you are being
terminated due to a formal request that
has been filed against you by our 25
year old marketing specialist named
Marcus a your name they [ __ ] snitched
on her so that's where I'm at i comes
concerned that the complaint wasn't
anonymous but there's nothing I can do
now I'm sorry this is so long big else
and you wanted updates thank you for all
the advice I'm glad that it's over with
Grunch please come to Texas oh my god
people are so [ __ ] stupid like so
[ __ ] you made her a target you told
him her full name and he knows where she
works and he can come by and yell at her
anytime he wants oh my god men are so
stupid like I can't believe I never
seems to be amazed at the stupidity of
men
well is this guy an [ __ ] or just
stupid or both I know it's like when he
didn't replied said you think he's an
[ __ ] but it is sensitive and I'm sure
he want to like talk to Pam and like
whatever get his chin his due diligence
oh yeah I don't think that was malicious
and he did the right thing it was
annoying that it took her three times to
ask but oh my god how dumb are you
maybe he was just trying to like throw
her under the bus like just in case he
ever does business with the weatherman
again but like ill like it's an air
conditioning unit like I'll send you the
$10,000 the toaster should raise ten
thousand dollars so this guy can get
over the [ __ ] air conditioning unit
we'll do an address giving him ten
thousand dollars do an ad for your air
conditioning company
Oh 100 percent one that we would have
but now no now we've oh [ __ ] that should
have been our advice like tell him the
toast will do man had instead of the
weather man
here's having to give me a commercial
air conditioning unit instead of the
weather man [ __ ] doc missed opportunity
I'm sorry I feel bad that really sucks
like now she has to move and now it's
like you did the right thing in
reporting it and like now you're just
being punished
literally I never understood the phrase
no good deed goes unpunished until
literally a year ago and it's so [ __ ]
true no that's the theme song of my life
any time I try and do something nice it
always backs like hits me in the ass it
never goes I'm kind of seriously oh wow
what a day what is that such a long week
it's only our second show and we're
still figuring out their same Fridays -
stay tuned I'll let you know for
Chilton's the answers they fully intend
on doing shows but New York honestly
very sadly has a dearth of talent it
really does but revolve is like hooking
it up but it's just like anyone who goes
to revolve it's like not necessarily
beaming with personality you know that's
a problem
teams is the one this specific trait
they chose like the it's like they
didn't want us to have a co-host I
understand
but I'll see about bigger e classic
revolve never thinking of us know and
it's like hello either in New York
thanks for the invite [ __ ] by the way
you're in New York and you did invite
some micro influencers we're gonna [ __ ]
are we you know you're in New York and
you didn't invite us but that's because
we talk [ __ ] about you literally on
every show so you're like working with
us giving us reclosed totally so it
didn't affect them I don't know I'm
confused me too but I just want to say
like I stood my ground did I ever got
the freaking honestly
so glad I don't have to go to Brooklyn
sittin but I just want to say like I
have values oh you didn't I never did I
didn't do it because of your values or
cuz you just swear to lazy well they
literally reached out about giving us
free clothes like six months ago then
they never responded it was like James a
day after literally they got in trouble
for only having skinny models and having
the shirt that says the Lena Dunham fat
thing they literally emailed me back the
day after like oh we need some fat
influencers like please I see right
through you and I'm not interested and
like a $500 credit gets me literally one
shirt and like I'll go to a sews and
spend $5.00 I'm still interested so I
was listening thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show people live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on Facebook and YouTube and we're
also available as podcasts on Spotify
iTunes and anywhere you can listen to
podcasts it's been an absolute pleasure
hanging out with you today thank you so
much for listening have an amazing day
amazing day check out our p-chan for our
home tour that's gonna go up this
afternoon
you